jisu unwilling to be stopped the turret
still in their eyes for this flight and
g2 a pullback
that's a pigsty gosh look at the fight
they look for killed number four this
might be an ace inside of the base
inside of 18 minutes the mid inhibitor
will surely fall and g2 rip through the
hearts of Team Liquid a North American
fans as they secure themselves in the
top of the world there is no chance TL
comes back from this there are already
our Nexus turrets this is what peak
League of Legends looks like and it
comes from Europe a world record g2
eSports 3-0
2019
[Music]
guys to quote quick shot where were you
when the West rose up the 2019 midseason
Invitational is at an end and for the
first time in almost eight years a
European team has won a riot
international title congratulations to
g2 eSports and to Team Liquid for going
the distance and making it an all
Western Grand Final
now if you missed any of the action over
the three weeks of MSI don't worry we've
got you covered with the best plays from
the play and stage the group stage and
of course the playoffs and the best
fails and funny moments now enough of me
let's get this video started with the
best plays from the playoff stage and
you heard it from the analyst test you
heard it from both analyst tests
actually this is gonna be a difficult
best-of-five for Team Liquid looks like
IG now the one for the backfoot Jensen
going in able to buy some time extending
into the backline fell on going after
the turret stay out of need that's not
gonna be able to find the damage and
he'll be brought down Jensen goes up
stop bollocks Mindy swoops in flash out
for the shot keeping himself alive
against the cataclysm as Jackie and
rookie make their way
to ban Scott from rookie double if taken
out expect is as well
IG dry G continuing this push they've
got 30 seconds left on fara Team Liquid
without their big engage mechanisms
gonna have a very to fill time if any of
them here we go
50 will to high G now in full retreat
the shines gonna be gone
shut down for jetson that teamliquid go
for for one disengage in time for JJ
going into the spacious bear in the bear
pit
you'll be taken down in the noble
sacrifice in fact wants to find a kill
on to me
that's looking for
they scatter the wards on the top side
of the map before moving down if I'm
cookie once one rookie is an absolute
hunter in the jungle he finds Xfinity
blows him up and give him the shot they
fit these into trouble get himself away
just barely but I came in for JJ
for Dylan both sides
where are you teleports themselves right
on top of Team Liquid I'm going to be
counter-attack instantly
here taken down blood more attacks
here's the deal
this gaming that teamliquid finds there
and this might be you can already see
the Fred minion 2000 can push in I
thought I would never say it again
i gr now 2 4 vs. 5 victor alternate
gonna be keeping core jjo a redemption
coming down keeping everybody top table
still looking to maybe find this fight
Hicks baby's gonna be
liquid we'll do it
one of the biggest moments in League of
Legends history Team Liquid takedown
wow it's really bad manners if I say I
want you to to win I'm gonna say I don't
know I don't know who's gonna win I
don't know who's gonna win but if I if I
play faker in the finals I'm gonna beat
him and Papa smithy we've got a spicy
game ahead of it I mean Taipei is
bubbling wet bubbling we're ready to
jump up and down like Kobe was yesterday
and which way it goes is so up in the
air we had a moment in time yesterday
another one is gonna be made today
there's no forest anyway it is available
for Khan Nicki's gonna walk in yet not
sub is the Queen's obliterating Mickey
in a flash for the dog body didn't
connect black shield is doing a lot of
work though for first yeah I can yank
our teddy is already used the flash
somebody he'll still available too if it
get caught up by the flail on the side
here comes the fall breaker lechuck's
and testing boys - Mickey's face card
closed the difference now matzo sitting
on that flash still got to be very
careful those spinny axes doing work
yeah Gus gets the shield cleaned and
yank Osprey lines 1 through 9 level 15
not yet annal tier 3 ultimate chance
attach the clip here comes an concerts
in Mickey who tried to make their way in
one is gonna be a little late to the
party
Teddy's coming into it from the backside
Ellison spent up to two weeks poor sweet
ghost alpha it's a train as that much is
taken out the damage done to Mickey
two-for-one that spot for cheap to step
four is rolling through SKT Capps is
looking a hunt down card that's a flash
board into the five point strike and
just to get a couple more autos and g2
with a convincing win to t2 it himself
with the first player is actually only a
100 goal difference between the two top
lane is now and the gold is actually
very even between the two teams as they
look for a playoff berth enchanted
crystal arrow comes down plate is
delivered with Martines too far away no
flash for first clean of corruptions on
cooldown as well with a devourer as well
as the void rush she sees that was such
a beautiful setup yeah lovely set piece
play long distance from downtown ash
ultimate on the exact recall spot
disengaged by the way cinnamon USS
that's a flashy impale will get too far
without not gonna get killed just yet
chain of corruption has already been
used here comes one that he eats an
enchanted crystal arrow to the face and
fakers been able to join the fray five
members of g2 trying to push board the
civilian way it's getting a little
turns around hijacks jitu chances listen
to that crowd as SKT turn it around the
Empowered rico is a tool that that faker
and sqt choose not to use fakest f-14
approaches faster spread perks as was
Mickey trying to do what they can
they've just waited enough for now caps
and wondered it pushing it this is gonna
be for the firefights this is the g2
classic they never go for conventional
and trying to end the game this foot
pushing right now rise towards the top
side here they go Lauren abyssal voyage
will deliver to the
that's an interrupter Devastator choice
to live aspects of the back line going
find the next act all of a sudden
there's a one-for-one support for AV en
casa as well as cap get themselves a
replies back now captain's attention to
car fakers running low if you need to
reach a wall
here's my cat capture story out every
single ability attorneys attention to
card
it's a Quadra kill g2 g2 esports hold
the line as the rest of sk team at one
last defense but it is not enough G to
look to eke wise the Serie 12,000 gold
advantage is a dog binding from Mickey
should just about seal the deal caps
goes all the way to the steps of the
fountain to equalize the series that
one-to-one will alleviate a lot of the
mat pressure that G to look took for a
piss poor man matzo just keeps getting
caught by these towards those skewer
goes up but that's a big miss for
wonderful cards found the damage on the
back end that oh good slicing those Tim
hasn't got any kills Yonkers is buying
some time but at what cost
that's a great Scout of the week but
it's SK Telecom not winning the fight
they turn their attention to Mickey he
goes golden for a few second one is done
nothing
you finally get to kill the because to
get that we said now the truck turning
around that's two before wonder he turns
it back click escaped with his life
all of a sudden captors left to learn
teddy chiju goose black bear and
empowered minions are pushing into the
face the gap beat damn champions can
fool gods can bleed where were you to
conquer champions who would have
believed it was North America's Team
Liquid versus Europe's g2 eSports and
here we are living away from here but
they will submit and they will knock
down one now here comes Nikki they're
gonna begin fighting several charms the
gun comes in before today great
journalist safety one they're coming
into the demonic ascension has a lot of
damage available explodes it for one
almost not static 50 no deaths just yet
if I could run away slowed down now by
at five
the better damage but
it's super cheap zoo and makin for it
has spawned very recently gain of five
minutes until Farrah's but the Midlands
already they're the best of the fence
just being shut down one kill picked up
ready to xfinity and look out for Jensen
rude shock wave is not going to be
enough they trade one for to the end of
it all and now Yenko is able to walk the
way off that kill yeah dad it's not over
and one who's gonna find the one is well
impact is Summit Earl is he's trying to
get away from the slope he's got Gorge a
chain but Yenko finds a naka now I'm
trying to theory him to safety pushed
away but Mickey I find it again you look
for the kill to support and they will
get yet another it's a to capitalize off
and they were able to get the out
topside looking for caps he does have
the Akali old under his links we can get
really really far GP now comes into the
squad look if it's damage against Troy
Jensen nearly picks up the kill their
reinforcements are in a stopwatch burn
and in goes cannon try to turn around
one four zero make it one for once when
there is now attic fifty trum and stay
alive or the kills just come through
fast and theory or Jay King said burnt
the guns get away from this one but that
is still a critical passage from
enchanted crystal arrow as one for it
does fall down a hook Internet back they
gonna burn him down he gets a stopwatch
off but not been placing Maelstrom here
comes
the perfect impact it's the one for one
so far to the back line Jensen finds a
second admit me as low for the team able
to push forward Team Liquid lose the
turn they win the fight now it's time
for round two Jensen is low cannot find
that kill it is cap who says he can get
the kill and sends him back to lissandra
it's rev3 know in this fight as the
channel comes in booked for the pool g2
can't kill number three and number four
is the load and he will they find almost
those Dinan yankles gonna bring the stop
watch this to be the teamfight and may
god
just slicing up teamliquid and suddenly
it's one versus the world and he cannot
stop it a clean ace and even as fast as
the last one G to look at a sub
30-minute win and they are a single game
away from your first ever MSI trophy
another fight now in the mid lane they
got plenty of image of that Jensen who
have to burn boast of us get out of that
one just afraid of what yankles could
have done to him this is the lane going
away and re-engage in the mid side they
find his son stopped by pops as well and
will it be any kills for tal force
outside of the cage caps he will not go
down without a fight get a replay back
onto the mid lane place so this time
around x50 is able to block a lot of the
damage going down onto Jensen capsid
ultimate cannot be converted into much
they go through the rule gauge and a
beautiful flash forward there they don't
find this opening is that menu walks up
it might reveal his location it's 50
trying to hide away they still don't
have the cooldown on syndra's old back
up the mitre for these Emperor here
being trying to QE nice juice by capo
will be hit a little bit they still Sun
comes in Oh comes in as well he's got a
lot of a play gonna play around with
they find that first time they find some
dearly but ignite means he will give us
- and cats tries it fridge at Cincinnati
here
J - slaughtering teamliquid
now obviously the playoffs provided us
with a ton of unforgettable moments but
the plans in the group stage had plenty
of highlight worthy plays as well from
Fong foo Buffalo taking games off G - -
I geez record-breaking nine and one run
here are the best place from the plains
and the group stage dominance I actually
got a teleport back and try and keep
this top plane turtle light they often
remembers he he should die not also
their audience here as well as Harris
who's gonna tell her he's gonna grab one
he's gonna look to grab another one
that's two zeros I cannot believe it bro
the Cataclysm in aadhi will grab it back
slowly swept everything out forced
detonation focused me out of the jungle
and then went for the two-man it does
not get crisper than you're gonna look
to land the prey seeker fought with the
altie but it might not be necessary the
sidestep though people say out the flash
gets a bit of damage down use zero still
alive goes under himself Oh
Saros takes a bite out our ex is a
little tricky to really hundred to zero
that Thalia but this is what I want to
say actually hooks off
at the pump at the resurrection gonna
have time five times we call the lab -
buddy God seen in it amongst the trees
and all the champions - streamed into
the jungle the shy trying to find
himself some sort of a play here wonder
down to one hit the shy wanting to make
it happen those forty I go through the
good job body blocking that shuriken
thank you so they can't do anything else
then gonna beat anger but sir at a crow
here for now the shot gonna be blood
King brings three bloods into the top
plane just five minutes the plans for
flash wolves at newer looking for a
purpose he's out flashes in for more
than CC is a good damage under the shot
first of all to give me the chip one
more hand okay a little minute solo kill
Hanabi with the Merc treads gets off the
stuns it gets the damage in they're
actually gonna try it now 41 Genoa now
stepping forward to tank impact I throw
down his ultimate a beautiful flash to
make it out to safety but there's just
too many members on the topside TV
coming in as well Sarris within an inch
of his life
yes who wants to keep the fight going
has the Jarvan ultimate Mellie Otis now
trying to tank trying to body boss
doublelift is on the way out as well
Sarah is now getting taken down a
beautiful turn by tal impact is still
alive core JJ here to attend the fight
CB trouble knocking America's doublelift
is now free hitting on Dena the shutdown
going through for Jen is the triple
count as many autoattacks 13 to 5 on to
Nexus turret were pre 16 minutes into
this game a big this game going to
battle [ __ ] not
Bangkok is got crushed four years ago
Invictus gaming / the world record they
smash SKT and IG are four pallets so
much team it's coming through four caps
he's gonna try to retreat caps now
backing off has to be careful perks is
here how comes the ultimate rolling back
this is Apollo going through a beautiful
arrow and purchase now he's already burn
the qsn smelly otis going to commit to
the play the rest of g2 is here but it's
no on the back side ready to keep this
one going miki still alive hurt still
alive
now it's wonder though dishing out so
much damage on the backside no buying
time but Sarah's here right on top of
parts he's gotta grab the kill was on
too passive gonna do more damage gonna
force the GA out of yang goes but nobody
had taken down the triple kill coming
through from wonder team able to clean
it up he made just look for the Penta
wondering for ya coming over going a
flash to poke a Penta what can he do
he's flashing forward trying to make his
way to Mickey Mickey will put some
damage does this good damage and apply I
do not
already there's one or two the shine is
now Nick is in trouble he finds they
killed Anton McKean he's escaping with
his life this rookies gonna cataclysms
it does he throw it down yes that will
be enough now checking up shows
attention to purchase is ripping apart
g2 caps needs to pop this GA teleport is
available for wonder he should be able
to join the fights in just a moment GA
gets caught Wanda has not teleported in
yet it is available is no response right
now for the plat
alright perfect execution father now get
stolen
it's raided caps doesn't even lose 10%
of his HP their eye decision-making here
well they're gonna punish boogie is they
take about half his HP up and now the
counter-attack come and in flash won't
look of a start this one off tepees
coming in from both of the top laners
score JJ is already gonna be eliminated
double trouble flash wolves while we're
in Team Liquid asunder
he's the g2 capstans wonder bust through
the work there's no ultimate more wonder
so this is gonna be hard gonna try the
dunk going for joys how to be really
good images arise staying alive finds
route flashing back to the pit
the smite is early account comes through
as well make it a second the solo laners
duplicate huge outlay there no four
rather in the mid lane but then once
again at the baron that ultimate 43 held
or left caps is able to get it with the
AoE and then look how he survived with
sub 3 digit HP they finish off all of
the kills in addition to stealing baron
just to continue the trend teleporting
on the shy that's a double TP caps and
perks all looking for the shy chaos tom
is available for him when does he side
for side steps the flag and drag grabs
if he'll comes on that will slow the
engage the shy literally walks away
that's all it cost to get to teller very
close to getting to the next stage it
here goes arrows though pretty good
damage pros full charge whatever damage
that is he's just gone he's just gone
Invictus gaming but now where's the
fight gonna go bow long gonna be caught
out here at Mickey X looks to protect
perch somehow Belmont has been killed if
IG tries to continue the fight they are
gonna be four versus five but the show
no way Danica looks to find the killer
he's gonna get the shut down he will
throw his life away for it caps drugs 2
1 vs. fries I'm gonna find himself a
single kill but also gonna be she goes
down teleport from Ricky and Ming
arrives in time that one decided to
teleport as one is going forward here
once again both team a liquid advance to
the semi-finals eliminating g2 thing
that I did and everyone that I
interacted with my whole career like all
the things that happened it led to this
so yeah I'm just feel really grateful
now as polished and professional as all
the teams and this entire event was not
everything is going to go according to
plan in every instance here are the best
fails and funny moments from MSI 2019 if
they meet you it's time for a break when
we return we'll discuss some players to
watch for the group stage can ask is the
shy the best player at MSI yeah yeah oh
well that's answered but we'll talk
about some other players too I promise
after that g2 and teams to be determined
in that group stage what steps is cloud9
going to terraces teamliquid going to
take to be successful be able to
actually finish this off and look at
Kats going in using everything to go in
stealing
[Music]
capsule city is dominant cells for such
a tense tiebreaker at the end of the day
yeah I don't think come on Damon be like
incorrectly huh the committeeman Daniel
um need ever warm air heating element
morning and once again they really do
just need time here on their a colleague
on their rise to be able to frankly
sadly that's the kill Vietnam erupts as
Invictus gaming are falling to fall is
just basically get out no we will not
the unleash power comes out and all
missus every skill shot don't really be
here in time for this pray
like there's the arrow announcing fight
the o'phelan a big car Oh they've got no
way to really save with a good shockwave
maybe it up it what's gonna try and dive
in but no I'm at straight in there with
the package moves into the back line and
that's actual demolition from Vega
squadron that's the ace I've now picked
up and Ralph is gonna feel rather good
about this one as he's got these small
CS lead I had to do it once it's like
it's too obvious it wasn't funny but at
least it was said was that a frisky
attack
nico in the top lane Vettius what do you
make of that into the shiz Victor well
right now we're getting a really good
pic dress if you of the Invictus gaming
looking calm cool okay it's uh it's very
very interesting blooded expectation
missions because really then winning the
World Championship before even getting
yeah
LPL Championship themselves that's to
them it really is a shell-shocked
situation today now my name is James
breakups alongside my bunk buddy all
things groovy it said that I absolutely
pulling Isaac is a Bentley you got a
small brain you've known me for a long
time I can own all right whatever one's
gonna drop that one you want to look for
something a little bit special you know
something like the Akane always don't
you
depending on what we stand up if you've
been sitting down to the start of a
massage today get out of your chest
a few phrases few exercises deep breaths
he's getting the full circuit you're
good you gotta get your flexibility oh
it's very good very close here comes the
big engage it is a 2 versus 3 though
advantage comes over to the Karthus now
it jump over the wall force and a flash
away from it Carl fold over first
kaalia kaalia
oh honey hold on you can kinda saw some
when you get it yeah from their regional
play if maybe it slows down a little bit
maybe there's a bit more a bit more
Breen a little less heart that comes to
do this one that was be part did you
know - and analysts at the Rob Moravsky
hamster's about the fastest and smallest
of all hamsters much like North America
as a major region they are the father be
eliminated with the smallest amount of
accomplishment and a thousand ninety
three days three years ago when North
America lost maybe my planet it's a bit
of a struggle now there are more haikus
coming ads I print they had faith in
hometown favorites and despite their
exit this haiku is next level missed a
buffalo don't underestimate him Stampede
is coming and going I'm going to turn to
my analysts and ask a question is clits
effective champion pool only listen and
job it ready gone get caught by the soul
shackles tower is now gonna be the focus
but it's at what cost
there's one kill for two towers that is
the definition of lobs worth the rev
tails gonna get another charge this time
on twenty Hibbert reg2 no-one's going
back are committing to the play where is
the support yang dose is down bottom as
well live and calm
in the back away how is secure already
and this may be number four rbis I have
no idea what you two are doing right now
they've just conceded so much gold to SK
Telecom he's going to be a juicy well
guys that about does it for MSI 2019 now
I know what you're thinking is Western
momentum going to continue all the way
into Worlds well I couldn't possibly
tell you what I can tell you is that
when and if that does happen we will be
there with all of the highlights all of
the fails and all of the funny moments
now that being said if you do want more
content like this I think you already
know what to do hit the like button hit
the sub button and comment below and
I'll see you next time thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you won't find anywhere else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]